if gp4 can train a robo dog better than
we can to balance on a rolling yoga ball
that's being kicked or deflated what's
next are we sure that changing a light
bulb or fixing a Plumbing Leak is much
more physically complex and if it's a
2022 era language model GPT 4 that is
doing the teaching what does that say
about the learning rates of robots
taught by even 2024 or era AI this Dr
Eureka paper was released less than 48
hours ago but I'll give you all the
highlights and interview Clips with two
key figures behind the Eureka concept
Jim fan and Guang Wang but first what is
the overall concept what are they
basically doing they want to train a
robot in this case a quadruped Robo dog
in simulation and see if they can
transfer that to the real world that's
the Sim to real part from simulation to
reality and they want to use a language
model in this case gp4 to guide that
process and why would it be helpful to
use a language model well if you have to
go in as a human and tweak all the
different parameters which we'll see in
a moment that takes ages as the paper
says that renders the process slow and
human labor intensive but this paper
isn't just about saving time the
language model derived reward functions
perform better than the human ones in
short language models like gp4 are
better teachers for robots so why do I
think this is so much more significant
than yoga balls language models like
Chachi PT are brilliant at generating
hypotheses generating ideas as the paper
says but as we all know their great
Achilles heel is hallucinations or
confabulations making stuff up making
mistakes but if those ideas even tens of
thousands of them can be tested in
simulation we can find just the good
ones thankfully language models are
infinitely patient and so what we end up
with are better implementations in this
case for robot training than humans can
produce and crucially as the paper
points out this works for novel or new
robot tasks ones not seen in the
training data of the language model and
this approach isn't just effective for
new tasks but for novel situations
within existing tasks we'll see how all
of this is done in a moment but here is
the G 54 trained Robo dog reacting to
the yoga ball being deflated it
overcomes that situation despite not
seeing that in training before we get
back to the paper though let's reiterate
something in the words of Dr Jim fan
once arrived in simulation this policy
is transferred zero shot to the real
world or translated it's not relying on
human demonstrations the robo dog
doesn't have to see a human or another
Robo dog balancing on a yoga ball no
fine-tuning it just works not every
single time admittedly but we'll get to
the blooper real later on I will need to
give you a minute of background on the
Eureka paper which came out in October
of last year before we can get to Dr
Eureka and let me try to summarize the
paper in less than 60 seconds a reward
function is a way of specifying in code
how to measure success in a task and
language models are great at coming up
with them and modifying them based on on
environmental feedback so the Nvidia
team proposed a task in this case
spinning a pen in a robotic simulated
hand then GPT 4 would propose a way of
measuring success a reward function of
course because it's infinitely patient
it could generate hundreds of these
these would be tested in simulation in
parallel thanks to Nvidia Hardware GPT 4
was then prompted to reflect on the
results then based on those Reflections
it would iterate the reward functions
spoiler alert it got really good at
spinning the pen at least in simulation
fast forward 8 months and we now have Dr
eure and no gp4 didn't go off and get a
PhD we're still using vanilla gp4 the Dr
is domain randomization which I'll get
to in a moment now some of you may
immediately put your hands up and say
what was wrong with Eureka couldn't that
have just worked for real world
deployment in a nutshell the basic issue
is that the world is kind of weird and
nitty-gritty there's a lot of physics
you need to contend with and aspects of
the domain or environment you can't
quite predict how much power will be in
the robots Motors and how much friction
will the legs have on the ball and then
some of you might say that's not a
problem just test every single scenario
but the problem with that is that in the
real world people have a limited compute
budget it's not practical in 2024 to
test every single possible scenario we
need to give the variables a realistic
range but not with human intuition with
llm intuition so let me now try to run
through the doctor Eureka process which
I think is genius as with Eureka we
propose the task what we add to Eureka
is a safety instruction basically gp4 be
realistic our Motors can only do this
much other things they say include this
policy is going to be deployed in the
real world be careful so then we get the
gp4 policy or set of instructions for
example controlling the legs of the robo
dog now this is where it gets a little
bit complicated so you might have to
focus taking that policy what they then
do is isolate each variable in the
environment in this case gravity but
then they amp it right up until the
policy breaks they bring it right down
until the policy breaks that gives us a
viable range where the policy works
that's the reward aware part and why
limit ourselves to that range well if
you set hyper unrealistic settings for
Gravity then we won't learn anything
these set of instructions will fail
every single time in that setting so
there's no signal back to the system of
what works keep things in a realistic
range and we get a more reliable signal
unfortunately though that's not enough
and that's where we need domain
randomization and to explain that I have
to give you a vivid demonstration at the
previous stage we were limited to ranges
for these different variables that could
at least sometimes work variables for
the bounciness of the ball restitution
and friction and gravity as I mentioned
there you can see the motor strength
range but there's no real Common Sense
here about what would happen with a yoga
ball that's why they called it an
uninformative context what gp4 generated
domain randomizations do is give a much
more realistic range based on common
sense notice how with each of the ranges
we get an explanation from gpc4 about
why picking that range for bounciness it
says we're not focused on bouncing it's
still relevant for minor impacts though
notice just between Zer and .5 for
friction it's thinking about tiles grass
dirt etc for motor strength it's
actually half of the full range and it
says this is a moderate range allowing
for variability in Motor Performance by
limiting the ranges we're going to test
we get much more effective learning this
is where gp4 starts to outstrip humans
in teaching robots in case you didn't
know by the way GPT 4 finished training
in August of 2022 how good GPT 5 is at
training robots only time will tell now
some of you in bewilderment will be
saying but Phillip why do we even need a
range why can't we just guess a value
for each of these things well the real
world again is messy by testing your
instructions in these realistic
scenarios it becomes much more robust in
the real world as we'll see the original
Eureka flops without this step before we
carry on some of you will be shaking
your head and saying I'm sure humans
could do better than this can't humans
come up with better reward functions and
more realistic ranges well here's guango
Wang describing how humans get stuck in
local Optima it has a very much prer
knowledge and therefore it can just
propose different kind of mutations and
variations of the reward function based
on the environment context for human
like you need to manually tune the
reward functions and it's very easy for
human to get stuck to a local Optima but
for gp4 it can generate tens of reward
functions at the same time and then
based on the performance of each reward
function it can continuously to improve
it humans simply don't have the patience
of larger language models or to bring in
some real numbers Dr Eureka trained robo
dogs outperform those trained with human
designed reward functions and domain
randomization parameters by 34% in
forward velocity and 20% in distance
traveled across various real world
evaluation terrains the grass pavement
you name it by the way they also did
other tasks like Cube rotations and
there again Dr Eureka's best policy
performs nearly 300% more of them within
a fixed time period more rotations for
your money if you will remember before
this we had to rely on domain experts to
manually perturb different parameters
such as friction and another problem as
I mentioned earlier is that then the
human would have to observe how those
set of instructions or policies did test
it in the real world effectively and
then try new reward functions all of
this delay is probably why we don't have
robot servants already to clarify this
is the first work to investigate whether
large language models like GPT 4
themselves can be used to guide this
simulation to reality transfer now what
about that safety instruction I
mentioned earlier why is that crucial
well this is where it gets a little bit
funny basically without that safety
instruction gypt 4 starts to behave in a
Degen at Fashion things got pretty wild
with GPT 4 but I'll give you the
sensored version basically it would
cheat by overexerting the robot Motors
or learning unnatural Behavior
essentially it would propose things that
conquer the simulation but which
wouldn't work in reality for example it
would try thrusting its hip against the
ground and dragging itself with three of
its legs now I'm sure that none of you
would try such degenerate Behavior but
gp4 did put that into the real world
though and of course that behavior
doesn't transfer with that policy the
robo dog directly face plants at the
starting line more forly though we got
reward functions like this and unlike
human design reward functions which
would involve adding each component this
was multiplicative the reward was the
product of the terms above and why is
that really smart well if any of these
tend towards zero the product will tend
towards zero if you violate the degree
of freedom of the joints of the robot
the entire reward function will generate
zero remember if you multiply anything
by zero it's zero whereas with the human
design policy you would add these things
up and still get some reward here are
some of the examples of the kind of
prompts they fed gp4 to emphasize
realism and safety the policy they said
will be trained in simulation and
deployed in the real world so the policy
they reminded gp4 should be as steady
and stable as possible keep the Torso
High up and the orientation should be
perpendicular to gravity later they say
please also penalize jittery or fast
actions that may burn out the motors
these kind of safety oriented prompts
were crucial here you can see GPT 4
reflecting on a reward function that had
failed and coming up with improvements
it was like ah I need an exponential
reward component for the height reward
so that the reward gradient is smoother
then it updates the reward function and
here's another way that that Dr Eureka
outperforms human training when humans
are trying to teach a robot a skill they
often come up with a curriculum a set of
things to learn in a particular order so
first they might teach a robot to move
at half a meter per second then 1 M then
2 m/s these curricula have to be
carefully designed well with this
approach we don't need a reward
curriculum it's almost like the model
throws out the human textbook and
teaches itself oh and why a yoga ball by
the way well apparently they were
inspired by the circus does make you
wonder what they're going to try next
but let's see and what about limitations
well if you remember from earlier they
didn't incorporate any real world
feedback but of course they admit that
with Dynamic adjustment of domain
randomization parameters based on policy
performance or real world feedback they
could of course further improve the
simulation to reality transferability I
actually had a discussion with Jim fan
about all of this back on my patreon in
January and one of the things we
discussed was another way to improve
this approach incorporating Vision if
gpc4 could see where the robot is going
wrong and not just read about it it
could do far better and how about one
more way to improve this approach
co-evolution apologies for the slight
audio deformity here I honestly I'm
struggling to see what the limit will be
and I'm wondering what you think about
the limit limit to the Eureka approach
as we get more and more powerful
models I think that is a great question
you know uh just by sh coincident right
like people talking about two star and
there like this renewed in in L
complying with classical purchase like
search right instead of just generating
you you generate and then you get you
see back and generate more you do a
little bit search and then you expand
that search and you know that kind of
coms back I mean fruit for model and
also just the the the intelligence of
the whole system and that urea is doing
exactly that right like it uses gz4 to
write reward functions and reward
function instru like a robot hand to do
the past and you get a feedback you know
how good that robot is performing and
you can use that as a gr signal to
improve even more which we did in the
paper yeah um and one limitation is that
we are not able to find chose GB but
it's possible that some of the old
Source models will catch Char in the
future and actually we are also actively
exploring how to use some open source
models in the loop for you well that
means we will be able to not just
improving context but also improve the
Intelligence on language which so
basically the1 and the urea and and the
robot they can cool and Co improve and
then you know for that limit like
basically the sky the limit or you know
comp budget is still limit right in case
you were wondering all of this is open
source and the links will be in in the
description but what about the bigger
implications I predict that within a
year we will see a humanoid robot
perform a complex physical dextrous task
one that is performed commonly in
Industry that could be the wake-up call
for many that the Blue colar World Isn't
completely immune to AI of course
there's a long way to go between where
we are and the mass manufacturing of the
robots needed to affect jobs at a big
scale so of course plumbers are say for
now in high stake settings like
self-driving we're clearly not quite
ready for widespread deployment although
weo is doing pretty well but for
repetitive tasks things might change
faster than you think and if you believe
that the dexterity of human fingers is
what will differentiate us then
Sanctuary AI will soon be on your case
and with AI doing the training in
parallel across thousands of simulations
things could change fast just an amazing
paper and super enjoyable to read and
yes I read many of the papers Linked In
the appendices I kind of went deep for
this one so thank you as ever for
watching to the end and if you do want
to support the channel check out my
amazing patreon we have incredible
networking on the Discord plus I do
podcasts and interviews and more but
regardless of all of that I hope you
have a wonderful day